how's film resumes welcome back to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] it off for [ __ ] sake
alright I'm gonna try not to swear so
[ __ ] much there we go oh god I forgot
I forgot helmet that's jab la balle I
hate this beginning here we go the clout
no I shouldn't have to do this again
come here you clown come on I ain't got
all day
really I'm Annie Lee la ba la you ever
stop and wonder what the [ __ ] you're
doing with your life
ah [ __ ] alright I don't remember
oh god please remember I think it's
something like that if I had let that is
black dodge the pitch and the jump and a
[ __ ] jump into me
come on I'm here oh god run run run run
run run run right right you have to run
and then there's just [ __ ] that's right
I'm cool I'm cool I don't mind doing
this again I don't mind at all like this
is my face when I don't mind stuff it's
small so my constipated face jump on
that ass jump on that is like you had
some J's and sass in your ways ah man a
knee
[ __ ] what is this Oh
MLG batch to batch ha ha ha alright
alright I'm ready now [ __ ]
don't win going going go you like with
you soon boom shocka smack aback I'm
Rackham we got this hold my hand
alright you [ __ ] more Yosh ah doesn't
matter cuz I'm Oh God not this jump
again I hate that jump alright how do I
do it again I go here I go here [ __ ] me
and then I die
alright got it [ __ ] you
alright this [ __ ] part again oh god
oh god [ __ ] me [ __ ] me if you can oh
yeah banana banana oh yeah oh yeah ah
come and get me
comic I'm sorry I'll ship up I'll just
focus I'll be a gentleman oh oh well it
look like I died
oh well I don't believe I died again oh
dear would you look at that oh my god
what an inconvenience
I want to shove razor blades up my ass I
don't know why too much tea for me I
need to calm down
why do you hate me that it's the
question cuz why did I ever
oh god oh god I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm so dead I'm so dead don't [ __ ] me
don't [ __ ] me I had one request in life
my request of not getting [ __ ]
Wellesley's mm oh jeez
[ __ ] how many bananas how many bananas
can a banana eat no wait they don't even
it up
I was too late until I realized the
bananas don't eat himself
they eat life the bananas are root of
all roots they are the root of all the
trees you thought I was gonna say
problem then yeah but I got one less
problem without bananas all right come
on you [ __ ] schmuck it's so fun it's
so fun Oh can't you play for me cuz I'm
having too much fun and I feel bad if
you're not enjoying yourself I'm this
sympathetic [ __ ] like that see
that's yeah that's some really fun
that's really fun you're a man not a
mouse and Mouse's don't my sis
don't know grammar properly okay okay
okay okay
maybe our okay can be our [ __ ] L all
right
I kinda have to I like video games
so funny when I die what am I supposed
to do what is that what is that clown
know something do something I'm giving
up on many more our elevators yeah but
you know what happened that cuz I closed
it that means we have to replay the
beginning why I love this game I don't
mind I don't let me me oh oh me I'm the
[ __ ] ass sticking [ __ ]
vagina keep it together
goosfraba goosfraba that [ __ ] in the
ass sorry I hate this part
I hate it oh ah jump already
whoo okay we're back oh no he jumped
that is stop it what the penis got me my
anaconda don't want none unless you
[ __ ] hon you're already getting them
here you're feeling tense feel I'm here
my name my name is my name is Alexis
feel it and feel it scattered the tone
she's kept out yeah ah scary at all yeah
Bluff is kept out so shad open cannibal
in oven so so many dead our get on ah
call me and now ha go up tricked you
[ __ ]
alright so I can trick the a [ __ ] I can
trick a [ __ ] stupid mother
[Music]
ah ah banked or get Magnus on just pet
my face or something
don't wait Betty hey pedigree my
pedigree [ __ ] sorry I mean Akane [ __ ]
it's working
whatever you do don't stop doing it as
so much ass so much ass why did you stop
that's my finger hurt from pressing down
the goddamn walking button too hard
balls it from fingering your mom's
[ __ ] alright huh
like I'm up here look I'm up here idiot
ah ah I'm up here I'm up here I'm up
here mini little alarm Craig
Craig's got it all ain't another FK it
coming from tickling ie you keep going
up
I keep licking your truck that is the
deal huh ah
oh he's nice to my hair it's nice tit
that is English don't don't
I'm up I'm up I'm already very he did it
anyway uh I bet you laughing Allah make
you think this is real [ __ ] honey at
least I have some sort of tactic how now
at least there's a little tiny shred of
hope asked
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I will never
do it again here I'm sorry are you okay
I'm so sorry I don't know what happened
sorry sorry I don't
madam na okay we can do this we can do
this approach a chose bro-chachos are
you with me are you with me broach a
chose are you wearing potatoes no well
are you with me potatoes up up now good
girl like Taylor Swift on the [ __ ]
VMAs [ __ ] was I don't my say how does
she pull that [ __ ] off that [ __ ] hurt
I don't care what it takes I don't care
it I hate you I hate you
immensely little meiosis Lydia unity
nope not gonna say that not gonna go
there Oh write it in go up go
I never been this [ __ ] pissed off in
my entire life about anything you could
do the worst thing ever
to me I wouldn't care I care immensely
why do I have to collect bananas out of
all God forsaken things why the bananas
just tell me why the bananas ha almost
got a [ __ ] and then you don't it's like
dating almost this game all right I got
this come down come down to earth you
[ __ ] ass licking mother go up okay
okay
we're still good gotcha [ __ ] come on
suck it up and that's just how do I get
that one
ah